Justin Jarrett
Ahh, Okay. Riesling.
I watched David Attenborough the other day,
and he said: don't be pessimistic.
There’s still hope and there’s still a future.
So I can see that agriculture still has hope and a future.
It's just that in 20 years time,
if you do want to be in agriculture and you do want to be in business, it is not
going to be like it is today.
You really have to shift
how you think about all the resources that we use.
It's how we use the water, how we use the soil.
What's our effect on the species that are surrounding the farms?
All those things really need to become priorities in a farming system versus the
economics of: I just need a return on investment.
If we can shift those changes, agriculture has a major role to play going forward.